I do have to compliment you you came out
here and it's it's striking right away
you've lost quite a bit of weight yeah
you know Conan I think because I
interviewed you a few years ago and yeah
you know I would just move on yeah you
know I wish somebody had told me I was
fat sooner no no one said anything to
you I think because I always pay all the
bills when my friends go out eating and
drinking I think they didn't want to
insult me right but I was really fat uh
you know the doctor put me on a weight
uh I've got to lose about 85 pounds I'd
gained a hundred you gained 100 pounds
yeah since I retired I mean and that's
no excuse for that just lazy so I'm
right at 50 now I've actually lost about
47.
thank you
plus you're gonna go 40 more after this
yeah 40 more pounds from here yes what
are you doing you just eating jello what
are you doing
no well if it tastes good I just spit it
out
quickly that is how it works anybody who
says
and still eat ribs and ice cream with
our special pill I think you see like
the the cookie diet and crap like that
no you know what you got to work out
like a mother I mean I work out like a
mother you know and I eat but like I
said I can if that's my thing if it
starts tasting good I get the juices out
then I spit it out
well I'm not going to Audi to eat with
you anytime soon it's disgusting you
don't want to go to the Sizzler with you
and you're like this is good bad to a
bucket Hey listen you got money now we
don't have to go to sizzling
no I know I don't want people to take
that the wrong way Sizzlers don't look
good for the salad what they got the
best salad bar I just like any
restaurant where you need a tray I've
always loved I have I love going and
getting food and putting it on a tray
it's like a really good high school
cafeteria
that's a that's that's a dead giveaway
once you're out of high school you
shouldn't use the tray anymore
you've got a billion dollars a day yeah
when I'm paid in Golden Shoes
when I was playing we didn't make a lot
of money
we were playing
in my day we didn't yeah that's right
you had to put in the old Peach bucket
didn't hear that
Sir Charles
that's right yeah you wrote from game to
game in a bicycle no but you know I of
course first of all I was clearly very
blessed yeah but they make a lot of
money today
oh my goodness gracious yeah God bless
them though I ain't no hater
I am Iverson
is better than me um
good friends also we're talking about
good friends you're friends with Michael
Jordan you guys he's like a brother to
me he's like a brother and apparently
you have very strong feelings about a
commercial that he just came out with
it's something that's bothering you you
want to talk about you know I
I thought it was just me you know when
I'm at work Haynes is one of our big
sponsors and I was looking at this
commercial
and I didn't say anything I was thinking
to myself I said whoa that's weird and I
look around and nobody else has said
anything then they show the commercial
again
and I look around I said nobody said
anything and they show it again I said
damn man don't you see Michael Jordan
got an Adolf Hitler commercial with this
commercial and they're like dude we
didn't want to upset you talking about
your boy and I said dude got a Adolf
Hitler commercial
for the commercials he grew a mustache
let's take a look at the mustache that
he's Sports now
foreign
I just want to clarify Haynes is not
doing Adolf Hitler commercials yeah
let's get a new one soon you know what
it's amazing to me when I saw that
commercials like when I'm making a
commercial
I did a Taco commercial and like I'm
holding a taco and this lady runs out
here full speed like a piece of cheese
is in the wrong place
I'm like it is and she brushes the
cheese with something to make it shiny
and I'm like dude got an Adolf Hitler
because on this commercial he got away
with that and I can't get a piece of
damn cheese in the wrong place
I like
um well I'm sure he'll fix it now you
should call him call him up and tell him
to grow out there he's probably gonna
get mad we're talking about this tonight
but he'll get over I'm not scared of
that guy all right I should be scared of
him no don't worry he can't find a lick
the greatest best basketball player ever
but can't fight a lick okay you give me
the dirt on anybody that's what I
thought about you